so yesterday we talked about the
governor desantis not familiar with him
debacle the 60 minutes see the governor
of georgia
uh no i think i know we've been talking
about jerusalem uh
he um 60 minutes at a hit piece
and um he's been having a lot of people
defending him
and no not a lot of people he's
literally everybody
everybody that doesn't get a w-2 from 60
minutes is defending him
statement from mayor dave kerner
democrat
or the mayor of palm beach county uh i
watched a 60-minute segment on palm
beach county last
night and feel compelled to issue this
statement the reporting was not just
based on bad information it was
intentionally false
i know this because i because i offered
to provide my insight into the palm
beach county's vaccination efforts
and 60 minutes declined the mayor of the
county
democrat mayor of the county did they
did like did they decline or like
not call him back because i feel like
they declined it's almost smarter right
to just not call him back and then at
least you have that plausible
deniability of like
oh man i'm going to fire my assistant i
had no idea he called
they know that the governor came to palm
beach county and met with me
and the county administrator and we
asked to expand the state's partnership
with publix to palm beach county
we also discussed our own local plans to
expand mass vaccination centers
throughout the county
which the governor has been incredibly
supportive we asked he delivered they
had that information and they left it
out because it kneecaps their narrative
we have confronted this pandemic for
over a year
our residents like all americans are
tired and the media is making it worse
they are hell bent on dividing us
for cheap views and clicks 60 minutes
should be ashamed
i thank the governor supporting the
residents of palm beach county because
of his efforts working in coordination
with palm beach county officials
over 275 thousand seniors in our country
in our county
which is over 75 percent of the total
senior population
have been vaccinated i am proud of how
our county and state leadership have
executed on this important mission
and the results speak for themselves
so can i read the somebody made a
transcript
of that ron desantis argument with that
woman
from 60 minutes and what they edited out
versus what they left in
because we even pointed out yesterday
wait a minute they cut a lot out of that
they cut a lot out of that so somebody
went back
wrote a whole transcript for the entire
[ __ ] thing
and put in bold lettering all the the
words that
60 minutes left out so
she does the you know oh it's pay to
play whatever and then he says that's a
fake narrative
they cut out everything after that where
he explains oh you have the thing pulled
up
i got you dude i want to i want you to
guys so
ever i want you to get to the part where
she says likes how's that not pay to
play whatever and he says that's a fake
narrative
it's the only words they left in was
that's a fake narrative
everything he says after this so it was
cut out i have what 60 minutes did and
then i have the full thing so
you want to do it back to back okay so
this is what 60 min this is what the 60
minutes in here we go
we caught up with them south of orlando
publix as you know donated a hundred
thousand dollars to your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination
so first of all that what you're saying
is right how is that not paid about that
that's a fake narrative
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator okay that's
already already already cut okay so
in between that's a fake narrative and i
met with the county mayor
here's what here's everything they cut
out here he said
so first of all when we did the first
pharmacies that had it were cvs and
walgreens and they had a long-term care
mission
so they were going to the long-term care
facilities they got the vaccine in the
middle of december
they started going to the long-term care
facilities the third week of december
and that was their mission that was very
important and we trusted them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites and you had
hospitals
but we wanted to get into communities
more so we've reached out to other
retail pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cvs and walgreens had to
finish their long-term care mission
as we said we're going to use you as
soon as you're done with that
but for for the publics uh they were the
first one to raise their hand and say
they were ready to go
and you know what we did it on a trial
basis i had three counties
i actually showed up that weekend and
talked to seniors across four different
publics
how was the experience is this good
should you think do you think this is a
way to go
and it was a hundred percent positive so
we expanded it and then folks liked it
and i can tell you if you look at a
place like palm beach county
they were kind of struggling at first in
terms of senior numbers
and then it cuts back into i met with
the county mayor
literally everything that he says
everything completely disarms what they
said
i mean and by the way props to desantis
i mean i know he knew this was coming
but a lot of dudes would have spurged
out or would have forgotten a detail or
whatever
but he explained himself as plain as day
and without notes or anything yeah we
played that whole clip last week before
this before we knew was coming out never
looked down at any notes or anything
he's like no i'm telling you i remember
everything i've done for the past three
months
here i'll lay out my schedule for you
all these [ __ ]
there's just this guy talking about it
missed on the decision that the
democratic head of florida emergency
management
says is false 60 minutes is caught
deceptively editing desantis's response
can it get any worse than that can't be
worse for them and
actually miraculously it can the
democratic mayor of palm beach
dave kerner came out with a statement
after 60 minutes his report
saying outright refuting the premise of
their story
saying that the story wasn't just based
on quote bad information
but that it was quote intentionally
false that he
offered to speak with 60 minutes and
they declined
and that palm beach themselves are the
ones who asked for publix to distribute
vaccines mayor kerner's line was this
quote we have confronted this pandemic
for over a year
yeah you don't have to like ron desantis
or any of this
to know that this is an egregious
mishandling of this entire story the way
by the crystal this part's funny because
obviously you know crystal ball doesn't
like ronda santa's but watch this
if they edited that clip was completely
ridiculous and the fact that
two of the leading democrats who were
involved in this thing are coming out to
back him
these people don't like him it's a swing
state they probably want to see him
defeated come november but it was so
egregious and it maligned
their own efforts in order to distribute
the vaccine that they said
screw you you're just clearly pushing
something well and here's the other part
of the trump effect
you are helping ron right now you're
helping
more popular than ever it's you i will
say this mike hadn't seen this and he
told me the same thing off fair he goes
you're helping the guy you're making him
look awesome
this they have managed to make uh
they've managed to create a bipartisan
like sentiment towards ron desantis
right now that's positive
and the thing is right here's the other
thing that people aren't talking about
the rest of the country and the
mainstream media have been calling us
unwashed wife beater t-shirt wearing
trash beach trash that uh don't want to
get the vaccine we're mostly trump
supporters
florida man oh i would never live in
florida those did
pieces of [ __ ] that's what we've been
getting for a year from you people
so you've kind of been making this band
together and then you're like and that
piece of [ __ ] governor now we've gotten
a point where we're like whoa whoa whoa
pal
you know we're getting a little [ __ ]
sick of uh of being maligned here
so you [ __ ] on us for a whole year then
you started a fight with our governor
and we're getting to that point now
where we're like look you want to
[ __ ] fight all of us at this point
cause like
yeah you get sick you guys talking all
this [ __ ] you've been lying about us for
a year
about our numbers about our hospitals
being packed about how we're all dying
out here
we've literally been [ __ ] renting
pontoon boats
drinking winning super bowls and getting
our dick sucked
not wearing masks everyone here is fine
and like we we're starting to see past
all the [ __ ]
and now you go like oh by the way let's
tell you about ron desantis
and i know some liberals around here now
that are going live they [ __ ] dude
they are really
doing a hatchet job on this guy and
there's a lot of small business owners
here that are very very grateful to him
for saying like no i have not only am i
not going to shut your business down but
i believe that i have no jurisdiction to
shut your business down
which is a way better answer than of
course you i i will allow you
to run your businesses like desantis was
like no
there's nothing in my job description
that says i can tell a bowling alley to
close
like that unless they have rats in it in
their kitchen it's like
something we can do but then every
bowling alley's going to close oh no
you're right
you're [ __ ] man just don't eat a polio
just go do you know what i mean
eat before yeah or after yeah and then
the bowling in the middle or bring your
or bring your own food in they have no
rules in bowling alley
they're like i don't care man i make
eight dollars they let you share shoes
you think they give a [ __ ] if you bring
food in
dude i make eight dollars an hour to
spray shoes with lysol
it's a pretty shitty job being him a
hero among republicans and conservatives
nationwide
you've now had these democrats come out
and basically be like this guy's doing
an amazing job
congratulations your hitch up just like
that oh yeah she's super hateable
everything about her is just hateable
yeah uh so he's
really skinny how about we hear desantis
himself talk about the hit job who are
the best
governors in the country we don't really
need to guess just ask yourself where
are people moving
are they moving to michigan are they
moving to new york are they moving to
california all great states but run by
total incompetence political hacks
corrupt people
no they're moving to florida actually
people want to live a free american life
for moving to florida
ron desantis is the governor of florida
and if you're the democratic party or
its minions in the media there's a huge
problem because
the guy's succeeding clearly that's what
people are moving to his states and i
better crush him
i'm gonna bet you money right now that
if you think tucker had trump's ear
tucker definitely has around the same oh
of course he does because trump was
way too proud proud and like
stubborn about certain things i
guarantee you desantis bounces [ __ ] off
tucker
he's like what do you think about you
know because tucker is a good
tucker's like everyone keeps saying
tucker for president i never see that
happening no
he's been smeared too much no he wants
it anyway i don't think he would
but tucker is 100 the kind of guy you
want in the ear of a president
that's like look if you do this people
are going to want to [ __ ] rip your
fingernails off i'm just telling you
like that's
that's the word on the street is they're
going to [ __ ] take a guillotine to
you if you do this remember when they
were trying to [ __ ] on trump and tucker
when there was like
yeah uh the reason uh uh we didn't go to
war with iran
is because tucker called trump and trump
listen and they try to make it out to be
a bad thing i'm like
i'm [ __ ] good good
so this is desantis thanks so much for
coming on
it's kind of hard to imagine i was just
thinking the other day all these people
moving to florida they're probably going
to try and take it out to santa's pretty
soon it didn't take him long did it
well not only that tucker but lost in
this is we
vaccinated now three and a half million
senior citizens we were the first state
to say we're doing seniors first
we're not going to follow the cdc's
recommendation and what we have done has
worked
and they didn't want to discuss that and
obviously they selectively edited
the background they tried to act like
there was a conspiracy with publix
ignoring the fact that other pharmacies
were involved before publix
doing all our long-term care facilities
and ignoring the fact that i met with
the county mayor
who's now as a democrat who said what
what uh 60 minutes has done is bunk
uh but the palm beach calculated 90 of
their seniors live within and look
let's point something out it's not like
this demo these democrat mayors that are
supporting him
like desantis they probably don't i mean
they're probably we're pushing for
gilliam to win and everything
but if you're the mayor of one of these
counties and these businesses are doing
great and they are
you don't want to be the mayor that goes
again because you're going against
you're going to all these businesses
that donate to you every year hey [ __ ]
you you know this is santa's guy's a
pizza you can't
they have you by the dick yeah you can't
what are you gonna say these businesses
are
are doing great people so here's what's
happening right
nationwide and and this is so desantis
got some [ __ ] right because
they were talking about the florida
unemployment in some states what they're
doing which which other states have been
doing have been
cutting off the eligibility requirements
to get unemployment which means you
don't have to
get applications you don't have to do
any of that if you say you got fire
because the cover we're going to give
you money
desantis came out and he said no no
we're going to have
eligibility requirements for
unemployment because we have jobs here
so they try to give them all this [ __ ]
but what's happening in other states
especially in the service industry is
now they're opening up they can't get
servers or people to work
because they don't need to prove they're
looking for a job and they'd rather get
the
the 1400 stimulus and the other one
that's coming up now here too
there's another stimulus that they're
working on already and get unemployment
versus going to a job so if you're one
of these states that have no
eligibility requirements if you're lucky
to go to a restaurant that's open
the service is terrible because why
would you
think about this why would you go work
and wait a minute royce do you mean to
tell me that a
entitlement-based welfare system
encourages people not to work
yeah are you insane yeah
that doesn't that doesn't sound right a
mile and a half of a publix
so when we put it in there their numbers
started going through the roof so it
succeeded there but
what they didn't tell you also tucker is
when there was a need in a more rural
part of the county
like near lake okeechobee we set up a
separate site in a small town called
pahokee they didn't tell you that
they didn't tell you that we were doing
african-american church
vaccination drives before publix ever
gave a single shot
they didn't tell you that they didn't
tell you that hospitals were doing shots
starting in the third week of december
because it didn't fit the narrative they
don't believe in facts
it was a political narrative it was done
with malicious intent
and a reckless disregard for the truth
they would not talk
to the people who were most relevant to
this because they know those key
democrats jared moskowitz mayor dave
kerner
would blow up their narrative so they
just put their head in the sand
and pretended like those facts didn't
exist
tucker really needs to work on his
resting face that's my favorite though
but he's so like he's either got a
creepy weird grin on his face
or a completely like it's the weirdest
he makes the weirdest faces i i didn't
watch the show because it's sad to see
something as great as 60 minutes so
thoroughly degraded as it has been
but really quick did they mention the
bottom line
number which is the corona death rate
how does oh we watched it tucker and i
can answer that question for you
they did not they did not mention that
florida's death because what's the point
that doesn't make him look bad we need
to make ron look bad
it has nothing to do with let's make ron
look bad compared to say i don't know
new york or california
well new york is one of the top in the
country florida there's 26 states that
are higher than florida
per capita mortality and there's 40
states that are higher than us for 65
and up mortality
i'm not gonna lie to you baby we got
more people dying on air boats down here
and uh getting eaten by gators that's a
big problem down here in fact we're
going to be asking the federal
government for some anti-gator funding
because these [ __ ] gators and air
boats are killing people left and right
tom brady broke his ankle on an air boat
last week but he said he'll be back in
time
i'm actually funding a study to see uh
if butch butch light attracts gators
cause that's a big problem here in
florida and right now my hypothesis
based on uh
our data here in florida it's yes yes
yes right now
[Laughter]
which is that was our focus and now
since we think the santa's wearing a
suit on top of board shorts on the
bottom
that's all he's just waiting to that's
not even a [ __ ] real
jacket it's like it's like a suit jacket
shirt and tie
pullover that he can pop on real quick
and be like
absolutely tucker he just rips it off
and he runs out and all you hear is
vacation all i ever want
while he's boogie boarding and he
doesn't even surf he boogie boards
he boogie boards he's floridian
vaccinated so many seniors we are seeing
the hospitalizations
among seniors plummet so what we did has
worked uh and obviously they were in
florida for three months 60 minutes
trying to drudge up any dirt that they
could use to smear me
and the best they could come up with is
a baseless conspiracy theory
that was easily debunked not just by me
which they had to edit out
conspiracies theory back in their face
oh ronnie i love you
bonnie boy i love you well here's what
happened with 60 minutes they were here
for three months right trying to
really rip into him and they did all
this work the problem is you can't now
if you're this
journalist go back to your producers
with nothing you can't go look you were
in florida for three months probably
this [ __ ] was hanging out at the beach
and partying enjoying all the florida
freedoms
she's vaccinated she probably got
vaccinated here if i had to guess
and you can't come back with nothing so
like what narrative what are we gonna do
when publix gave them money
all right how can we make that into like
publix pay to play
i'm actually thinking about that now too
like you're [ __ ] you're right
how ironic would it be if all these
reporters came here secretly just to get
the [ __ ] texting
and then the whole story is about how
ron desantis isn't let is letting people
cut the line and people aren't getting
the vaccines
they literally have the band-aid right
here on their arm and they're like look
this is bo oh sorry this is [ __ ]
this is dumb
all right